today on the matt walsh show the cancel
culture claims
three victims last week prolific week
for the canceled culture we'll talk
about the latest cases and discuss
what might be done to finally put an end
to this madness also five headlines
including
the most notable events from the super
bowl if there were any speaking of the
super bowl
the washington post is concerned that
the buccaneers mascot
may normalize piracy yes i'm not joking
we'll talk about that as well and much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know there's never been a more
important time to protect your online
data uh it's especially important now
the past year that we've just been
through
uh to make you know it's we already we
all know it was a tough year in general
but
it saw on top of everything else many
cyber security attacks including data
breaches network infiltrations bulk data
theft and sale identity theft ransomware
outbreaks
and the large shift of employees working
remotely has coincided with an increase
in attacks more people are online
which just means that the um the bad
guys are working overtime
to take advantage of that a recent study
suggests that remote workers have become
the source of up to 20
of cyber security incidents that
occurred in 2020 which is why it's so
important to understand how
cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet
and you could miss certain identity
threats just by monitoring your credit
uh or by looking at your um your bank
statements things like that that we we
should all be doing but if that's
if that's the only thing you're doing
there are many threats that you're not
going to detect
lifelock is a leader in identity theft
protection and that's why you need them
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats and if they detect your
information has potentially been
compromised
they're going to send you an alert and
if the worst does happen and
and you know you have a problem with
your identity being stolen whether
there's identity restoration specialists
on staff
that can offer you protection and
defense on that end as well
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses
but lifelock can see threats that you
might miss on your own join now and save
up to 25
off your first year go to lifelock.com
walls that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off this past week was
one of the cancel culture's busiest and
most productive to date
it began with the country superstar
morgan wallin getting suspended by his
record label pulled from hundreds of
radio stations and disqualified from
receiving country music awards after he
was caught
saying the n-word on tape and it ended
with
donald mcneil jr famed science reporter
veteran journalist of 45 years being
forced out of his job at the new york
times
after revelation that he had also used
similar quote-unquote racist language
and in between
old accusations of inappropriate
behavior by another new york times staff
member
andy mills prompted him to also resign
in disgrace now
getting getting into these specific
cases in mills case
it apparently engaged in some
inappropriate flirting with women at a
previous job
several years ago now this is all known
this was known and it was dealt with at
the time
apparently but after it was decided by
some people on twitter and some of his
colleagues that mills had not received
his fair
fair portion of the blame for a separate
incident in which the times had to
retract
key portions of a hit podcast that he
had helped produced
these other unrelated allegations were
made to as they say
resurface as for morgan wallin as we
covered on the show on friday
uh he did say the n-word but it was
uttered drunkenly
in jess to a friend and secretly
recorded by a neighbor
and then sent immediately to tmz donald
mcneil
used the same word though it turns out
that he said it
one time two years prior while on a trip
with students to south america and he
didn't so much as
used the slur as referred to it now as
he explained in his resignation letter
he quote was asked at a dinner by a
student whether i thought a classmate of
hers should have been suspended for a
video she had made as a 12 year old
in which she used a racial slur to
understand what was in the video i asked
if she had called someone else to slur
or whether she was wrapping or quoting a
book title
in asking the question i used the slur
itself
this incident was investigated
internally by mcniel's employer right
after it happened
it was determined that he had no
malicious or racist intent he was just
referring to the word he was
talking about it and trying to be
understood and in the process he used
the word or rather referred to it
but once this was all made public two
years after the fact
the times brass quickly lost their nerf
now adding to the pressure from social
media mob were 150 time staffers who
sent a letter to their leadership
professing to be
outraged and in pain outraged and in
pain
because someone had referred to a racial
slur two years ago
they demanded his removal quickly got
what they wanted
executive editor dean bequettes who
initially defended mcneil but collapsed
like a folding chair the moment real
pressure was applied wrote a letter to
his colleagues on friday
announcing mcniel's departure and
stating that the company does quote
quote does not tolerate racist language
regardless of intent
this is the common thread between both
wall and men and mcneil's cancellation
the insane unjust wholly indefensible
notion that intent
doesn't matter in human communication
all that matters to the canceled culture
and to the quaking gutless jellyfish who
cater to it
is how a word or action makes somebody
feel now a second thought i should
rephrase
it's not that the feeling matters more
than the intent
you know that would assume that those
150 staff members who said they were
in pain because of a word that donald
mcneal said two years ago
were being sincere if we say that
all that matters is their feelings then
that is to assume that they were
actually feeling
in pain is to assume that they are
merely oversensitive emotionally
unstable babies
whose psychological fragility has driven
them close to madness
but that's not the case see one of the
hallmarks of the canceled culture what
makes it distinct
and also modern is that the angry
pitchfork mob
is rarely angry they ruin lives they
ruin reputations they ruin careers
as a matter of course more indifferent
to their victims than angry at them
they're motivated by cruelty callousness
ideological conviction and they're
empowered by the institutions that run
our society that's the other thing about
the canceled culture
that must be understood it is inherently
a left-wing phenomenon
you cannot really cancel anyone that is
ruin their career and turn them into
social pariahs that's what cancelling
means right
unless you control the institutions and
the culture itself
as covered last week the right may
complain and justifiably so about for
example
nick cannon calling white people animals
and savages
but the reason he got his job back after
a brief vacation is that the
institutions don't really care
what conservatives think or how they
feel
the institutions do care very much about
what leftists think and how they feel or
pretend to feel
and this is a fact that the the leftist
mob is well aware of and uses to its
advantage
that's how cancel culture works and what
it looks like
it is cruel it is callous it is vengeful
it is emotional only in a performative
sense and it is intensely ideological
what cancel culture is not what it is
the opposite of
by definition is forgiving
merciful and that's precisely why the
groveling public apologies from its
victims are always so impotent
as they were in the most recent cases
morgan wallen sent a statement to tmz
saying that he was
embarrassed and sorry and apologizing
and promising to
quote do better mcneal published his own
statement conceding that he originally
thought
he could defend the use of the word
based on context but now he realizes
that context doesn't matter
he now realizes how quote deeply
offensive and hurtful his language was
and he's sorry to his colleagues and
regrets letting them down
but what what mcneil should have said
and might as well have said
is the truth as an adult a professional
and a human with a rational brain
he knew in the past and still knows that
context
matters when it comes to language or
anything else in fact in fact
when it comes to language especially
context is the only thing that matters
or it's one of the only thing that
matters
you can't possibly know what someone is
trying to say what they're trying to
convey unless you do an honest
assessment of the context
of that language he also knows that his
colleagues who lined up to stab him in
the back
and feed him to the wolves after nearly
five decades in the business are not
deserving of an apology
they are the ones who should apologize
to him for their wretched callous
evil manipulative behavior as for wallen
the neighbor who filmed him was
obviously not so traumatized as
as to prevent him from immediately
sending the video to tmz
you know traumatize people that's not
what they do they don't they don't send
videos to tmz
and the social media mob if you read
what they've been saying about wallen
they don't appear to be upset or injured
at all their attitude
is more of a ha we got another one
variety
so who is he apologizing to exactly
you'll notice that ever since the advent
of the cantal culture
there has never been one apology
accepted
there has never been one example of
reconciliation and forgiveness
and that's because the apology doesn't
matter
it's all part of the performance the mob
does not listen to it they don't
consider it they just claim it as a
trophy and
a scalp to nail to their walls that's
all it is
the apology is coerced under public
pressure delivered to parties who are
not injured by the offense if there even
was an offense to begin with
and then gloated over or else snidely
disregarded by the people who demanded
it
i i can't say what will end canceled
culture
or if anything ever will but what i do
know is that it certainly will never
end and will only get worse as long as
its victims keep apologizing
as long as they keep laying down and
offering themselves up as
carcasses for the vultures to pick apart
now i believe in apologizing in the
correct
context that is when when you've done or
said something to
actually hurt another person and the
apology is given sincerely
and voluntarily to the injured party
but this this ritualistic ma public
apology thing
has to stop even if you were wrong
for whatever you did or said to provoke
the mob
still you should not apologize to them
not to them never to them
you should be as indifferent to the
mob's fraudulent display
displays of offendedness as they are to
your whole life
and reputation and career and existence
they don't care about you at all they'd
be fine seeing you destroyed they don't
care if you go off and kill yourself
they really don't and you care about
their feelings
why the only way this ends
if it ever does is if the targets of the
cancel mob stand up for themselves
and display the righteous indignation
they certainly feel and have
every right to feel and if they
absolutely refuse to submit and kiss the
feet of people
who are the real villains here
the cancel culture mob they're the real
villains
in the movie the crucible after john
proctor um
refuses to sign a false confession
admitting to witchcraft
thereby signing his own death warrant
right before he's taken off to be hanged
he kisses his wife
and he says to her give them no tears
show them a stony heart and sink them
with it
those are his last words to his wife
pretty great last words
and this is the advice that i give
anyone targeted by the mob
show them no tears don't pretend to care
about the emotional well-being of
sociopaths who want to ruin your life
just for fun
many people in your life may deserve
apologies from you for many things that
you've done
god knows i know that's the case for me
but not these people
never them so stop apologizing
and this may not stop this may not stop
your life from being ruined
if your time comes up on that stage that
nobody wants to be on
where you're getting torn apart yeah i
mean your career
your reputation it might all be done and
it might be not there there might not be
anything you could do about that
so at least keep your dignity and
respond the right way
and if enough people do that then
eventually
maybe this ends
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know if there's one thing we love as
americans i think it's one thing we have
in common we don't have much in common
these days but here's one thing at least
we all love
underdog stories don't we we all love
that and that's why you have to check
out the true underdog podcast raised in
a trailer park with no clear path to
success
kicked out of high school multiple times
faced with becoming a father and his
teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog
after hearing the words no or you can't
too many times as we've all heard those
words he unleashed the power within to
start three successful companies with
his most recent venture
power home solar skyrocketing on a path
to becoming a billion dollar enterprise
so join us as waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year shares
motivational tips and inspiring stories
and um also gives tips on how to build a
business from the ground up he shares
his life experiences and that of his
high profile guests
to help others better themselves you can
learn about failure you can learn about
entrepreneurship learn about
never quitting never making excuses it's
real it's raw it's motivational
uh and so i think we could all use maybe
some motivation in a time like this as
well so check out
true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com or anywhere
you get your podcasts um okay the super
bowl happened on sunday in case you
didn't hear
patrick mahomes loses in a blowout i
mean it really might be time for the
chiefs to uh consider
moving on from him i don't know i think
that uh they tried it it's not working
probably offer him up for a trade might
be able to get a third and fourth round
for him or something like that we'll see
meanwhile tom brady wins his uh
seventh super bowl which i think
definitely cements his status as the
second best quarterback of all time
behind
colin kaepernick so he's he's right
there behind him at this point
but you know here's the main thing
though as i was watching the game and i
was i was
uh you know looking at some of the
reaction on social media because the
game itself was not very interesting so
um you know you look for other things to
to uh be interested by
the commercials also weren't great we'll
have more on that a little bit later in
the headlines
but um looking at some of the the the
reaction everything
and there's um a lot of discussion about
the game
everything associated with it but but
for me the thing that stands out and
that i'm trouble troubled by frankly
is that a lot of very upset chiefs fans
are complaining about the officiating
right they're saying that the bucks were
getting too many
pass interference calls going their way
and so on and you hear this complaint
any time tom brady is involved in a game
there's always the claim that the refs
are on his side and everything
well i couldn't help but notice that
this was also the first super bowl to
have a female ref
so the sexism of chief's fans
is just unbelievable here to
to complain about the job that the refs
are doing
only because a woman is doing it i mean
you're telling me this is a coincidence
first time a woman is officiating and
now all of a sudden people are
complaining about the refs never heard
those complaints before
strikes me as sexist the sexism in
kansas city is um
really upsetting to me on a on a deeply
personal level
all right moving on number two this is
from ksl news
it says investigators are struggling to
build a federal murder case regarding
fallen u.s capital officer
police officer brian siknik vexed by a
lack of evidence that could prove
someone caused his death as he defended
the capitol during last month's
insurrection um
authorities have reviewed video and
photographs that show sicknick engaging
with rioters amid the siege but have yet
to identify a moment
in which he suffered his fatal injuries
this according to law enforcement
officials familiar with the matter
soon after sicknick died on january 7th
prosecutors in washington open a federal
murder investigation dedicating a team
inside the u.s attorney's office to
build out a case
to date little information has been
shared publicly about the circumstances
of the death of the 13-year veteran of
the force
including any findings from an autopsy
that was conducted by the dc's medical
examiner
it goes on a little bit later it says
according to one this is
very interesting according to one law
enforcement official medical examiners
did not find signs that the officer
sustained any blunt force trauma
so investigators believe that early
reports that he was fatally struck by a
fire extinguisher are not true
uh one possibility being considered by
investigators as signic became ill after
interacting with a chemical irritant
like pepper spray or bear spray
that was deployed in the crowd but
investigators reviewing video of the
officers time around the capital haven't
been able to confirm that in the tape
um or at least they haven't been able to
do that so far so this is a this is a
case that
it's it's odd how little we've we've
heard
at least when you when you consider the
assumption or the reports early on as
mentioned here
that officer siknik was you know in fact
you still see the way it's portrayed on
social media the way the media talks
about it
you know the phrase that we've seen is
uh is
brian siknik was was beat to death by
the rioters or something like that
and you hear about that it's of course
awful either way it's a terrible tragedy
because a police officer lost his life
but if he was beat to death by a crowd
in dc you you would think there'd be
video of it i mean hundreds of video
cameras all around
people in the crowd filming security
cameras i mean there's just cameras
everywhere
and it sounds like there's plenty of
tape for the investigators to look at
involving siknik and they've been
looking at it and they have they haven't
been able to find
this particular incident um
so it's just it's strange how little
we've heard
and then you consider it what makes it
harder at least for us and the public
to sort of sort through is of course we
know how the media
we know what conclusion the media wants
after all the media what they've done is
they've actually tied
three officer deaths to the riot
there's officer sicknick and then two
others
that they've tied to the rioting even
though there's two other cases those
were officers who committed suicide in
the days and weeks after the riot
now to turn that into a riot death
is just so cynical and misleading that
it's almost unbelievable
it's almost almost as shocking that you
would have people doing that
with no basis i mean what even is the
insinuation there
you're assuming that they committed
suicide because they were so upset by
what happened at the ride i mean that's
that is quite an assumption to make
without having any information
there unfortunately lots of reasons why
people do this
and without knowing anything about these
uh
these officers to just assume that it
was connected somehow to the riot is as
i said
cynical and totally dishonest and
disgusting
but this is what the media is doing you
know they want to get the riot body
count up and they want to be able to say
that it was a deadly riot which is what
they are reporting
now we know first of all that that no
matter what it was a deadly riot because
we do know for sure at least one person
we have video evidence
that at least one person was directly
killed by violence in the riot but that
was
ashley babbitt who
was a rioter herself and she was shot
and killed she was an unarmed woman who
was shot and killed by a police officer
but i think when the media calls it a
deadly riot they they don't want
that to be the only fatality they could
directly connect to the rioting
then there were three other people who
were at the protest to um
who who and i say protest because
there's you know not everybody there was
engaged in a riot
okay despite again how it's portrayed by
the media there were three other
individuals
who were at least part of the protest
who died and i believe we know in two of
those
cases those were medical emergencies
after the fact
someone had a stroke or someone with a
heart condition the third case i'm not
sure but that's sort of the point that
this is it's just
we're hearing five people died in the
riot but
we're just not being told very much
information about any of these cases
except for ashley babbitt who's just
sort of being ignored completely
and it does matter i talked about this
on twitter yesterday and there were some
people getting
upset for some reason and saying well
how dare you ask these questions about
officer sicknick well what do you mean
of course it matters
either way it's a terrible tragedy
nobody denies that i least of all deny
that
now in fact people on the left who are
mourning sicknick
in fact i i actually don't believe that
they see it as a terrible tragedy
because he is the only dead police
officer that these people have ever
mourned
they have never shown any concern ever
for any other police officer
except him so i do actually doubt the
sincerity of their feelings
but as for me i in
support of the police always have been
so i of course it's a terrible tragedy
but why he died and how he died
i would say that matters very much would
matter to me if i was
the family it matters legally it matters
in every sense
yet the way the media reports it is well
he died writers killed him
don't ask any questions
okay number three let's see here ibram x
kendi
um anti-racist expert got himself into
some hot water with the woke
crowd uh that's his crowd because of
some comments he made about gender
recently this was during um starting
some sort of
zoom meeting or seminar that he was
involved in
now you you all know i've talked about
before that the victim hierarchy
and how that works on the left and even
rex kendy
you know his position on that hierarchy
that that gives him the freedom to say a
lot of things but it does not give him
the freedom to speak freely about gender
the way the hierarchy works so he's not
at the top of the hierarchy and that's
how he got in trouble
for saying this you know obviously
talking about race even
talking about gender you know i think it
was last week
my daughter came home and said she
wanted to be a boy
you know which was horrifying uh for
my wife to hear myself to hear and so of
course
you know we're like okay what
affirmative messages about girlhood
you know can we be teaching her to
protect her
from whatever she's hearing in our home
or even outside of our home that would
make her want to be a boy
um and i suspect it's the same thing
with you know
kids of color in which they're regularly
hearing these messages that maybe
may want them to want to be white um or
even white children who are like i'm
happy i'm white
right you know what affirmative messages
are are we teaching them to to break
down those ideas
now the thing is almost everything he
said there was
correct except for the last part at the
end it's i if i i didn't quite
understand what he meant at the end it
sounded like he was saying
that it's a problem for a white child
who's happy to be white
um taking that aside
everything else he said you know if your
daughter comes home and says she wants
to be a boy uh yeah that
that is horrifying that is horrifying
because number one
this is your child saying that she
doesn't want to be
who she is she's not happy with who she
is at such a fundamental level
as a parent of course that's a problem
and that's what he's touching on here
it's
a very good point it's a point that i've
made many of us have made many many
times
that if your child we hear so much about
well
we have to help kids accept themselves
for who they are and
be themselves and all these things and
yeah you're right
but if a boy is saying that he's a girl
telling him that yeah you're a girl that
is not ex
helping him accept himself that is
helping him reject himself
so the the problem that he has is that
he's not
happy with who he is or he doesn't fully
understand
who he is especially if we're talking
about a kid who's like four years old
saying
if a boy you're saying i'm a girl this
is a child who just doesn't doesn't
understand there's nobody's talking
about
doesn't doesn't really know anything
about the world and very little about
himself and his own identity um so he's
confused
as you get older a child comes home from
public schools and middle school or high
school
is saying this well this is someone
who's this is a child who's
who's dealing with with something
dealing with despair dealing with um
confusion dealing with you know
self-loathing all of these things
and if you really love them and care
about them as a parent
then what you're going to do is help
them to accept who they are
your daughter comes home and says i wish
i was a boy
what's the correct message from a loving
parent
the correct message is no you're a girl
that's a beautiful thing that's a
wonderful thing
it's wonderful to be a girl that's the
message
but of course not allowed to say that
even ibra mex kendy isn't allowed to say
that
and he has participated in making this
woke brainwashed culture where those
kinds of
very common sense and important insights
are not allowed to be uttered um
number four biden president biden on
friday was talking about the need for
another stimulus
and i still think somehow that these
people are missing the point here's what
he had to say
only 6 000 private sector jobs have been
created
and at that rate it's going to take
10 years before we get to full
employment it's not
that's not hyperbole that's a fact we're
going to be in a situation where
take a long long time and uh
i appreciate you all coming over because
and the urgency with which you're moving
this about people's lives this is not
just about numbers it's about people's
lives people are real
i don't tell any of you they're really
hurting people are being
evicted just look at all the number of
people who are
needing and seeking mental health
services now
suicide's up people are very really
really drug abuse
violence against women people are really
feeling the whole they don't know how to
get out you've given them a lot of hope
a lot of hope but with the as they say
in southern delaware the grace of god
the good will of neighbors with
kryptonite rising we can really
begin to do something consequential here
yeah this the way that the people who
lead this country don't understand
anything about human beings and human
nature that that is it's uh
it's troubling to say the least
i mean he's right that suicides drug
abuse all these things are
on the rise obviously they're tied to
the lockdown the fact that people have
been isolated the the fact that people
have
had their careers and businesses
destroyed
or kids that i just just we just ripped
them away from their education from
their friends from their lives from
from sports you know there's so many
elements especially what we're doing to
kids that it's it's hard to
focus to give all to give each specific
element the focus it deserves
but even just that i mean i i i've been
talking about this for a long time with
what we're doing to kids with the
lockdowns
and i realized that i hadn't thought
much about this particular element
of it even just the sport part of it
you take a kid as a maybe a
junior in high school when all this
started he's been working at a
particular sport maybe hoping for a
scholarship they've been
you know working for for a long time ten
years or starting in little league or
whatever it is and rec league and then
going in high school
and then we just we just take that away
from them
what happens now can they still get a
sports scholarship can they go back and
maybe the last one or two years playing
the sport take it away
so that's one one thing along with
everything else we've taken from kids
and from people generally
yeah that's a that's a huge problem but
you're not going to solve
that problem by simply continuing to
give
people money i'm in favor
of of giving financial help
the government giving financial help to
the people that it has financially
ruined because they owe that help
i'm in favor of that but that's not the
solution
especially for something like despair
loneliness
a 2 000 check is going to do absolutely
nothing for that
not one thing
the way to solve that problem is to open
up the country again and let people get
back to their lives that's the way you
solve
that problem although you can never
totally undo the damage that's been done
number five okay back to the super bowl
a couple other things i wanted to
mention
um first of all the uh
there was a big deal being made about um
a show
debuted on cbs after the game a reboot
of the equalizer
and that was originally a show i think
from the the 80s
about a retired kind of ass kicking guy
who uses his special skills to you know
bring bad guys to justice
equalize to equalize things
and then there was the film with denzel
washington and that film had
a real gritty kind of violent vibe to it
with denzel as the no nonsense
take no prisoners hero um and now the tv
reboot and the person in that role which
debuted yesterday after the
show and i watched i think i watched
maybe um 75 seconds of it before i
turned it off
but the in the reboot the person in that
role that was most recently filled by
denzel washington
is uh queen latifah
and i know we're not supposed to say
this even though we all think it
but i cannot take a 50 year old woman
seriously in the role of a gritty
violent ass-kicking action hero like
i just can't um i'm i'm sorry we've go
the woke pc stuff and girl power stuff
it's
like there's a limit with it and i think
we've now reached that limit when
queen latifah is stepping in for for a
you know a role most recently filled by
denzel washington
um in the preview the first scene of the
preview
she walks into a room with a bunch of
gun-toting bad guys and beats them all
up with her bare hands this 50 year old
woman
i mean you know i understand it's it's
fiction
okay i get that but the problem with
putting women
in all these roles is that when you do
that all semblance of reality
must be removed from the story and yeah
it's fiction but
you want it to be especially if you're
going for gritty action kind of thing
drama and all that you you want it to be
related to reality in some way
you want it to exist in a universe
that's recognizable to the viewer
otherwise it's hard to really get
invested in the story
and so in order to turn all of these
things into girl power
type shows and movies you have to make
them glossy and cartoonish
there's another scene in the preview
where um
queen latifah is standing up on a roof
where we know
in shows that that's where all the
important meetings happen for some
reason is on a roof
i've never had a i've never had a
meeting with anybody on a roof ever but
uh
i'm not sure i've ever even been on a
roof really but
she's on a roof and another guy comes up
and uh
and she says to the other guy well what
are you doing up here why'd they send
you
and he and he says to queen latifah well
you would just kill anybody else who
came up here
and you look it's like queen latifah
it's hard to take that seriously
we're supposed to be intimidated it's
supposed to be intimidating sort of
figure
you could buy that for denzel washington
tough no-nonsense guy
all right that's the first part the
other thing um that was after the show
before the show amanda gorman who's the
slam poet
who we were told was a sensation because
she performed at the inauguration
and now apparently we're doing slam
poetry before super bowls too
and so she performed before the super
bowl and here's a little bit of that
today
we honor our three captains for their
actions
and impact in a time of uncertainty
and need they've taken the lead
exceeding
all expectations and limitations
uplifting their communities
and neighbors as leaders healers
and educators james has felt the wounds
of warfare
but this warrior still shares his home
with
at-risk kids during covet he's even
lent a hand live streaming football for
family and fans tremaine is an educator
who works
non-stop providing his community with
hot spots
laptops and tech workshops so his
students have
all the tools they need to succeed in
life
and in school i mean isn't that
so that's talking she's she's talking
i just good good job with the talking uh
it's not bad talking you know
as far as talking goes pretty good i
give it a solid b
plus in the talking department but i
that's you're talking with emotional
with an emotional
background music that's that's it
that's just that's just not poetry at
all there's there's
in no way is that poetry
i don't know i just so i i contin i
continue to be
flummoxed by by uh by this
yeah like i said pretty good talking but
i'm supposed to be i'm supposed to be
impressed
i don't what am i supposed to be
impressed by maybe someone can explain
it to me
i don't quite see it i also not sure
what i'm supposed to be impressed by
here the um
this is making a lot of waves bruce
springsteen
was uh involved in a jeep ad and uh this
is supposed to be we all
we all love the inspiring commercials a
lot of inspiring statements made by the
corporations
corporations always making inspiring
statements they made a lot of inspiring
statements during the super bowl
for example before we get to the g-pad
anheuser-busch
the the makers of budweiser beer they
made a big deal before
the super bowl that they were not going
to play any they were not buying any
time for budweiser ads
during the super bowl because they
wanted to make a statement about the
severity of
a coven 19 they were going to dedicate
all that money to raising awareness
about the vaccine
and so they weren't going to play any
budweiser ads and it was a great
great thing but they still had bud light
ads
and they also ran an ad for
anheuser-busch
and in the ad it featured people
drinking anheuser-busch products
so that might be the emptiest
and most pointless example of corporate
virtue signaling
i think we've ever seen which is saying
quite a lot
make a big deal about not running ads
for this one product
but then the company that makes the
product still at ran an ad for itself
and for its other products so very
inspired
um this too from jeep and bruce
springsteen i don't know
you tell me if you're inspired by it
let's watch
there's a chapel in kansas
standing on the exact center of the
lower 48.
it never closes all are more than
welcome
to come meet here in the middle
it's no secret the middle has been a
hard place to get to lately
between red and blue between
servant and citizen between our freedom
and our fear now fear has never been the
best
of who we are and as for freedom
it's not the property of just the
fortunate few
it belongs to us all
whoever you are wherever you're from
it's what connects us and we need that
okay there you go yes it's what connects
us
uh we we all have to come together by
buying a jeep see that's the thing even
if i were
to be even even even if i were tempted
to
be inspired it always comes back to the
fact that yeah well they're trying to
sell a jeep though that's that's really
what this is about they're just trying
to sell
a car a vehicle um
and so it kind of kind of detracts from
the inspiring message
but also this is this is
of course nonsense coming from bruce
springsteen from a corporation
when they say oh let's meet in the
middle let's unite let's let's come
together
what they mean is where we're meeting is
not really in the middle
it's on the left that is always what it
means
what they are inviting you as someone
who is wrong
and backwards and stupid they are
inviting you to give up
all of your wrongness and your
backwardness and your stupidity and to
come
join them um in all of their rightness
in the in the glory and light of their
rightness
that that's what that means but then the
thing is even that is not really sincere
because we've found that that even if
you were to do that and abandon all
all of it and try to come join them
they're not really going to let you be
part of the club
or at least before they'll let you you
have to you have to
you know uh express your
your there there are there's atonement
that needs to be done
for all of the horrible things you you
have done in the past and by horrible
things you've done in the past we mean
just
the fact that you have disagreed with
them for so long
so that's the real message we're not
meeting in the middle we're meeting on
the left
you're invited to come over to the left
maybe if first you atone for all of your
sins
and even then you still might not
actually be allowed
not as inspiring when you put it like
that before we get to our daily
cancellation you know got to tell you
about uh our very good friends over at
rock auto
uh this is this is the one of the i love
all of our sponsors this is definitely a
sponsor that i
find myself using quite often maybe more
often than i would want you to be honest
just because
one of our cars is sort of is older now
in their senior years
and so we're having problems with it
more often than we like but what that
means is that we're you know we need we
need auto parts
and i'm grateful that we can go to
rockauto.com rather than
going to an auto parts store all the
time and the thing is
you go there the selection isn't great
the prices are definitely not great
and oftentimes they're not going to have
what you want they got to order it
online you're paying more for that
why do that when you have access to
rockauto.com at your desk and in your
pocket rockauto.com always offers the
lowest prices possible
um they're gonna they're gonna charge
you as little as they possibly can
and that's what it comes down to
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been doing this online for 20
years
and and you know that when you're there
you're going to get an amazing selection
you're going to get reliably low prices
and there's going to be all the parts
your car will ever need at rockauto.com
and also you know the catalog is really
easy to navigate even for someone like
myself you can quickly see all the parts
available
for your vehicle and choose the brands
the specifications and the prices you
prefer
so go to rockauto.com right now see all
the parts available for your car truck
right walsh in there how did you hear
about us box
so they know that we sent you well one
other thing to tell you about
um you've probably heard me talk about
our all-access membership before but for
those of you who haven't heard me talk
about it
it's our most elite membership base here
at the daily wire
these are the the top of the top cream
of the crop our all access members
receive two leftist tears tumblers when
they sign up and uh being an all access
member means that they get to watch
full coverage of all daily wire shows
not to mention our feature film
and soon to come entertainment content
what's more they get to tune in to the
exclusive all-access live which is a
show featuring different daily wire
hosts every day
and um we just have a conversation with
uh it's just a back and forth
conversation it's a lot of fun
so today we want to publicly thank all
of our all-access members for their
commitment to the daily wire
and to show our appreciation we are
mailing out a special anniversary
tumbler
for all renewing all access members this
year
so if you renew your all access then you
get this special anniversary
tumblr not including the sloth the sloth
come
i didn't need to i didn't mean to take
it against this take it out against the
sloth but the sloth
is not part of the deal what you get is
this uh is this leftist tears tumbler
on the front you've got your classic
leftist tears and on the back
you see there on the back you have all
of our signatures
is mine on there yeah it is okay there's
gonna be big problems if my signature
was not on this thing
uh you get all of our signatures
including mine and a short statement
about our belief that america's best
days
are still ahead of us this is a
commemorative piece for our five year
journey and a thank you
to all of our all access members in
particular for supporting
uh what we're doing here so cheers and
make sure to renew your memberships
and now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
okay today for our daily cancellation um
come on down
jamie lh goodall your next stop for
cancellation jamie goodall is a staff
historian at the us army center of
military history but what brings the
cancel hammer down on her today
is a piece she wrote for the washington
post a couple days ago
in the lead up to the super bowl the
headline was
the buccaneers embody tampa's love of
pirates
is that a problem and then the
subheading how brutal outlaws became
romanticized yes goodall is
is concerned that we're romanticizing
and normalizing pirates
she's after all an expert on this
subject as she has a giant tattoo of a
sexy pirate on her arm
and no i'm not making that up she really
wrote about the problem of romanticizing
pirates
with a romanticized image of a pirate
imprinted permanently on her body
but i'm not going to focus on that
aspect of the issue too much after all
we can't expect
her to have a consistent view on the
crucial issue of pirate romanticizat
romanticization i mean it's something
we've all wrestled with
and found ourselves on different sides
of i think um i myself went through a
heavy
pro romanticization phase i used to walk
around with an eye patch and everything
i
told everyone to call me captain
brownbeard even spent a few years
swashbuckling buckling on the high seas
just a normal teenage phase
and i have grown out of it as so many
kids do but i still prefer to be called
captain brownbeard if you don't mind for
the record
but in any case uh goodell writes of
tampa's pirate mascot she says while
this celebration of piracy seems like
innocent fun and pride in the local
culture there is danger in romanticizing
ruthless cutthroats who created a crisis
in world trade when they captured and
plundered thousands of ships on atlantic
trade routes between the americas africa
and great britain why
because it takes these murderous thieves
who did terrible things like locking
women and children in a burning church
and makes them a symbol of freedom and
adventure erasing their wicked deeds
from historical memory
these were men and women who willingly
participated in murder torture and the
brutal enslavement of africans
and indigenous peoples goodall then
finishes with this thought she says
perhaps time has dulled us to the
atrocities committed by these 17th and
18th century outlaws
which side note i mean yeah it has it's
actually
really normal and healthy for the
emotional impact of atrocities to be
dulled after
400 years i mean you really shouldn't be
actively upset about
anything that happened four centuries
ago
which isn't to say that you should
approve of everything that happened four
centuries ago it just means that
400 years is a very long time and it's
not where we should focus our emotional
energy
anyway she continues um or perhaps it's
the fact that if pirates of the golden
age were bloodthirsty so too were the
nations who oppose them
they willingly and purposefully
massacred millions of african and
indigenous peoples in the name of
colonization
pirates then are seen as romantic heroes
the underdogs fighting the establishment
whom historia historian marcus redeker
refers to as
proto-democratic egalitarian and
multicultural
should we celebrate their complicated
legacy it's a question tampa bay has to
contend with as we
collectively contemplate other major
sports mascots with dubious legacies
like their super bowl rivals in kansas
city
okay um no tampa does not have to
contend
with that they really don't there are a
lot of things that tampa does have to
contend with like alligators and
mosquitoes
but the legacy of piracy no not really
see there's a term we're starting to
hear more and more often on the left
especially among academics and the term
is
problematize okay and what this means
literally
is to make something into a problem to
take to take something that is not a
problem
or they would say is a problem but isn't
seen as a problem
and get people to see it that way the
left believes that it must do a lot of
problematizing because we're all too
stupid to see when something's a problem
we're so dumb and so clueless that we go
about our daily lives
completely oblivious to the great threat
posed by
17th century pirates and that's why we
need them to explain to us
that this is a problem in our lives even
if all evidence
points to the contrary but in truth of
course
there is no problem not until they
create one
you know most people don't think much at
all about pirates i assume
but if they do think about pirates
they're quite aware that pirates were
humans not
actual cartoons they're aware that
pirates were criminals and killers and
thieves and so on
people know this people might also be
fascinated by the idea of adventure on
the high seas
people can be fascinated by that while
also
intellectually recognizing the moral
shortcomings of pirates
these are thoughts that the average
person can hold in their head at the
same time
it's not a problem and if the average
person enjoys reading stories about
pirates
it's because they're interested in that
period of history and yes the people in
it
so what but see that's really the point
here and it's one of the big problems
real problems i mean not manufactured
problematized problems
with this never-ending effort to remove
all popular reference to historical
characters and historical periods
the problem is that if anyone is
actually influenced by a reference to a
pirate
or let's say a viking because we'll get
around to the vikings of course
they were unsavory characters too
sometimes um or a cowboy or a civil war
general for that matter
if people are influenced by these
references
they aren't going to be influenced to
imitate whatever bad things those people
may have done
if they're influenced they'll be
influenced to discover more about these
people
and the era in which they lived and to
learn more about them and therefore
develop a fuller understanding of
history and their own place in it
if there's any influence that is what
the influence will be
the mascots the monuments the school
names all of these references to history
cartoonish or otherwise
for most people you know these things
have no impact or resonance at all
most people pass by the monument every
day without noticing it
they see the mascot they don't think
about it they attend a school named
after a historical figure and never
wonder who that guy was
but for the five percent who do stop and
look at the statue or consider the
mascot or
wonder about the dead guy whose name is
on the building they're going to be
influenced to read
to research to learn that's a good thing
that should be encouraged
you see that's the opposite of a problem
the problem is the absence of that the
lack of learning
the disinterest in history and the
people who want to
get rid of the mascots and statues and
building names and so on what they
really want is a population that lives
as though human history started five
years ago
they're trying to breed ignorance and
disinterest
which might seem like an odd claim to
make about you know the writer of this
article as she's a historian who
apparently specializes in pirates
but it seems that that wokeness has
deluded her to the point that she
deleted her so much to this point that
she wants to reduce public exposure
to the very subject she spent her life
studying
an even better example would be
the san francisco school board which
recently voted to change the names of
over 40 different schools
effectively canceling dozens of
historical figures all at once including
abraham lincoln
well the new yorker has an interview
with the head of the san fran board of
education gabriela lopez
and it's clear through the course of the
interview that
this woman gabriella lopez simply has no
clue
about the people that she wants taken
off the school she doesn't really know
anything about them or about american
history in general
and she wants to make sure that the kids
in her schools are as ignorant as she is
so here's a sample question and answer
from the interview
question i think a lot of the commentary
about the school names is focused
specifically on lincoln
it seems to be the thing that a lot of
people are the most upset about
do you have any thoughts about lincoln
and how we should view him
here's the answer from the um head of
the department of education
um she says i think that
the killing of indigenous peoples and
that record is something that is not
acknowledged
it's something that people are now
learning about and due to this process
and so we just have to do the work of
that extra learning when we're having
these discussions
and later she continues i think lincoln
gets more praise than the
how can i say this yeah i don't know i
don't think that
well lincoln is not someone that i
typically tend to admire or see as a
hero because of these specific instances
where he has contributed to the pain of
the decimation of people
that's not something that i want to
ignore it's something that i'm learning
about and that i know it's not spoken
enough about
now weeding through that um
that uh uh just jumble of buzzwords and
nonsense the translation here is
this [ __ ] doesn't know a damn thing
about abraham lincoln
and she's typical of the people waging
this battle against american history
they are utterly ignorant of the thing
they want to erase
and ignorance is the goal disinterest
apathy anything that makes
history intriguing any figure who
committed the sin of being interesting
or important
all of that must be forgotten
just erase american history completely
of course for schools and for historians
their goal should be the opposite of
that but again they've been so deluded
by wokeness
that they're now doing the opposite of
what they should be doing
and for that the history cancellers are
themselves
cancelled and that's going to do it for
us today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show time magazine
acknowledges that elites secretly
manipulated the levers of powers during
election 2020
and the new york times fires a reporter
for not being racist
that's today on the ben shapiro show